danger sections of the callao and if not what
you have to know they are infamous point
barrancones level the godfather
know they are crazy hangout simmons ceviche
restaurant
wants to leave your asenjo fan shower
ay ferrari marco garcía who cause
for the subject of kidnapping for the subject
normal
frame and are ex-con with the work of
local callao prison providing with headquarters
in made to keep the man from vending
harry list decided to change is
ways up is akin to live altering
experience and it was so hard because there was
Christmas time in which my son
called crying living that is a
his side
they were already telling me that it is not right
the rest
that my son was already into robberies
used weapons
when I left
I'm not doing a job
fiction calls me
to tell me he was dead but fine
tortured but no longer work
Sign in the stone in the mouth
the fingers had no busts
I had a nascent bullet
let's investigate this enemy only
I got two weapons
I will get to continue
and a whole month
something
one more day
[Music]
nothing has come because we love
blood theme blood of thanks to evade
grease
if I could not save my
I'm going to save other young people
marcos sanz guasch poli fortin no
I would go back if they are criminal good son is
brutal and mariel
[Music]
age of 14 years old I had first
gang we were 25 out of 95 4 died
11 we went to prison, the
our gang when we already had
we treated the 11 prisoners the best
almost those who stole what we expected
this they eat in the market
when I had my second homeland at 16
we make it back with the same
we lose weight of the penal institution
of minors from here of peace then in
these times the money in the traffic of
drugs so I me with my girlfriend
with both sides we started to traffic
they found me with a certain amount
of drugs and I was imprisoned in the prison
many things happen there are no friends and no
brothers there is nothing you are alone and nothing
more already leaving prison here in the
This street I did not want to return to
I myself learned the art of cooking but
it was pretty good I have two cebicherías
Now I only put forward for cooking what
more is not anymore is not to make money
just forged great know sound market
the present framework water union in respect
of what the safety and is guaranteed
there was the news the streets
[Music]
if it seems to be found
[Applause]
to that pod it no longer understands everything
I had it for so much
and black I'm calling you because they have
killed pepito for many the street and
this but to the account that few who
they have to kill you were a kid
it is the nephew of a friend who is
Delegate here in the penitentiary and insurance
I was on the street for a lot of the street
for more acquaintances there could have been
endorses his good
active to the right right
[Music]
with hannover and tekken of several from
the beginning of the common
fixation cause
this is not a big evil
something we have to do something we have
take
we are in your house
ah
Excuse me press closing the Lord has
what to do with the murder of the young man
guaita no of camps are good tele ni
simple broad zhang wareham caps
you take the words
of family
[Music]
Y
he put it today for the marches
because the boy
your son
delicious
we have to be there to have them
loose do not tell the man because
I know they're going to give money to cut it
the man well k who have the leg
already tormo
but as if it were a creature
in the organization miguel degree here in
the callao where the body of
antonio flores espinoza antonio flores
spinoza and other criminals would have
asked for a taxi per application a taxi from
the uber company to assault it was
so that this young man that delinquent
15 years old takes the key away
driver and noticing the assault
made several shots 10 casings
were found in zone three of
they hit against Antonio Flórez and
not in justice
a person older than a young man there I go
to leave dead lying on the hand
the basketball player station
completely from mcguinness with pepito
as well as helguera white driver al
20 not what I have
the taxi driver driver
the husband living
of warcraft
yes
carol see the police smart monitor
investigation
what we know about the verifications is
that a taxi driver is called a taxi driver
comes to that place is the interposed
client is there, enter the car
immediately two people put them
some weapon in the neck get out of the
vehicle and reacts and makes use of its
weapon he had he has made several
shots and already victimized a child under 15
years but you have to accept a
criminal investigation for
determine if there has indeed been
in self-defense
very many
outside the police station very large
pepitos father who was eagle and waiting
for information on the word waltz
'taxi driver' yonkis angle
a virtual 10 of private of rafael and the
markets and go the heavyweight within
prison and walt disney some athlete
athletes and one water and hold pavilion
of prison of local prison channel
guantanamo derives from the fire of shorts of the
narrow of the local person and will not
survive neat form of youtube
frame you cloud friend of 16 hits
family is attending wake and I shouted
twitter
Daddy came all aggressive has gotten
with your whole family
they have taken the field not be the force
then we are not waiting for you because
they have promised that at seven o'clock
at night they will pray
[Music]
in the leg and in the stomach
possibly 5 in the stomach
and now as we read and open abertis
with him
What I wanted with my son
he understands what he has wanted is I trust
that what is imprisoned
I want
[Applause]
what happens to the shot that happens
sessions and do not have me the criminal
sarita colony
truly
many things but that's not talked about if
the man has to pay to have that
pay but is a person who is
hurt can react in a lot of way
[Music]
this question
Of course, if we limit you
the truth
and if you leave the tweet dj love the callao
in my family
article the coffee
u2 the harvest lived in command
hams from emails or penitent prosecutors
of prison the cetis the favorite to the side
of coffin prison intro about
giants x final football
frames almost came a walking in and out
of here the night time is money paint
angel pencil inside inside
the month is what he told me that the
justice is in charge does
walker
sanderson
from end to eco-friendly was made to win can
dance alone side whole floors
in typical callao fashion
youtube the fire to infinity
the police with love from fire in life
humanity brands
we respect nobody
waiting
the loss of a woman
play indies by topher callao with you
are in charge
the decision 'not to have watching expand your
activity and plants form documents
ladies one and visual of our series
with your new shirts you said fit next